I knew you would come here.
Luculia.
Why are you here
when the program is over now?
Because I thought I could see you again
if I came here.
Tell me, Violet...
Who is the major?
You always ask at the end of your letters
if the major had sent a letter yet.
Isn't he the one you really
want to send a letter to?
Why don't we write a letter to him today?
Not like your usual reports,
but a letter with your true feelings.
I won't leave until we're done.
Major...
I'm sorry.
I don't even know
what I want to say to him.
Because I do not even understand
the meaning...
of the words he told me.
Violet, why did you want to become a Doll?
I... want to know what "I love you" means.
You want to know what "I love you" means?
It's hard to communicate
your feelings, isn't it?
The truth is, my parents died.
The only family I have left...
is my brother.
I don't know what to say to him.
When the war began,
my brother got drafted.
But there wasn't much fighting
in the Western Front
where he was deployed.
The fighting was always taking place
far away.
So, the war didn't feel real to us.
But...
one day, when my parents
went to Herne for business,
the Western Front was broken.
They couldn't find any trace
of my parents.
And then the war ended.
-My brother came home alive.
-Come on, give me one drink at least!
Give it a rest already!
I wanted to be happy
that at least he was alive.
What the hell?
-But...
-Shut up!
my brother was angry that he wasn't able
to protect Herne.
He blames himself...
for our parents' deaths.
Don't show your face around here again.
I was just...
happy that he was alive.
I just want to tell him "thank you."